[音楽]
の
a まずは
こちらの方を見ていただいてもよろしいですか
これ
なんだかわかりますか
これは
ある
アイデアコンテストで最優秀賞を取った
作品です
タイトルは
食べて病気を治す飯場ガンバ
と言います
アイディアはこんな感じです
ハンバーガーを食べると
小さくなって
悪い所まで1
レタス
丸ののこぎりで
悪いとか聴いておりますそして
パテニックを移植し
トマト薬を塗って
最後
チーズ絆創膏
完了
という夢のような
全自動の手術ロボットです
そして
こちら
これは
電気を貯める雷鳥
と言いますがどんなロボットかわかりますか
この
雷鳥は雷のエネルギーを貯めて電気のアマゴを生みそれを被災地や
電気のない所に持っていけるという
こちらも素晴らしい作品になっています
今はまだ奇想天外だ
アイデアですが
近い将来
これが実際に素晴らしい
製品になる可能性は
十分にあるのではないかなと確信しております
ところで子供たちはどうやってアイデアを
形にできたと思いますか
こうした作品を作るためには
夢を描くイマジネーションと
それを形にするクリエイションが
挨拶です
私が作った学校は
様々な実体験により
2つの想像力を豊かにし子供たちの主体性を引き出しております
子どもたちは
憧れる見本があるを夢中になってものづくりをやって駅いますが
そう言っ工夫しながらクリエーションの想像力を伸ばして
いきます
ただ私が意外に思ったのが日本のない状態で
a マダケを示すと子供たちは
途端に手が止まり
悩んでしまいます
どうやらこの2つの想像力を育てるためにはそれぞれ違う方法が
必要だと気がつきました
私述べたいなぁ時代を思い出すと
当時は
いつも
ワクワクしながら
こんなトラクションがあったら子どもたちは喜ぶだろうな
をもとにイマジネーションの創造力を引き出す品歩を使って言いました
それは
そのままで
新しい使い道はないだろうか
と言う
テンヨーのヒント
似たものがないか
他からアイデアを真似できないだろうか
と言う
王様の審判
e 3
形色
そして動きを変えることができないだろうかという変更のヒント
そして
組み合わせてみてはどうか
合体や混ぜてみてはどうか
こういう
結合のヒント
そうだこれだ
私はこれをヒントにイマジネーションの創造力を引き出す
ゲームをいくつも思いつきました
今日はその中でも一番効果のあったものを持ってきました
同市西黒と
名詞サイコロ
二つを合わせてワクワクアイディア
サイコロゲームを読んでいます
使い方はサイコロ振って
偶然でた
サイコロ
をありえない動詞と名詞を組み合わせて
未来にあったらいいなをキーワードにアイデアを出していきます
例えば
陥る
決し5
が出たとします
皆さんこの起きる気仕様でどんなアイデアが思い浮かびますか
ある子どもが
こんなアイディアを出してくれました
この
起きる消しゴムは
めざまし月の消しゴムで
時間を合わせておくと優しい音楽でを起こしてくれます
でもなかなか起きなかったら
前の夜がんばっ終わらせた宿題を
決心まくりますどこですか
絶対飛び起きてしまいますよねこのアイデアサイクロを使うと子供たちは遊びとして
楽しみます
どんどんアイデアが浮かんできます
イマジネーションの想像力が育っていくわけです
このあの子遊び感覚がものすごく
重要です
入って教えない
何もないからこそ
学ぶのです
さて最初にお店痛いしました
こちらの作品
これは食べるなおすっ
とを誘導しにハンバーガーという
名刺を結合し未来にあったらいいなあというワクワクが合わさって
生まれました
そしてこちら
こちらは
アメル
雷鳥
こういう
通常あり得ないコンビネーションと未来にあったらいいなを感じて感じた時
自信家
大風で
停電の出来事が今回の作品につながりました
予測不可能な
社会を
生きるには
主体性が必要だと言われています
それは
未来にあったらいいなを発送し
形にする力です
この
二つの力をバランスよく
鍛えることが大切です
そんな力を育てていければ社会はもっと楽しくなると思いませんか
では
最後に
握る
というボスと
ロボット握るロボットの2つの要素と私の2つの想像力でどんなものができたと
思いますか
それでは
値切るロボットの登場です
ん
えっは
はっはっは
はい
腕を上げろ
なかなか上げてくれないですねー
ヴァッハウでわけだぞ
腕を上げろ
2切れ
ec 方ですありがとうございました
政府が流行っいい